how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
things are really getting going with
marvel's phase four the falcon in the
winter soldier has finished filming
spider-man 3 has just begun filming and
we're going to be getting the wanda
vision series very very soon
and today i have a quick video talking
about the one division series because we
got a couple of really cool updates
recently and in one of those updates we
have some really great news because it
does seem like the one division series
is still on track to be released
this year in december and this is
actually confirmed by kat dennings who
of course plays darcy lewis in the thor
films and now
in one division in an interview with et
she was asked when it was coming out if
they were trying to get it out this year
still and this was her response
we'll find out soon it's coming out
pretty soon so
later this year right december that's
what i've earned
but i also don't know anything so oh
like it could change
possibly it could but as far as i know
they're they're gonna try to get it out
this year yeah
okay so so luckily for us the kovid
delays have not stopped it from trying
to get out this year and it looks like
according to kat dennings they are
indeed going to get it out in december
so we only have about a month to wait
until we finally get this show
and according to another actress on the
show tayonna paris who is going to be
playing monica rambo it's going to be
quite the action-packed show
in a recent interview with gamesradar
she said i'm so happy to be a part of
this universe
and to be monica rambo she's such a bad
a
in the comics i just can't believe that
this is happening this is a full-on
action movie mixed with sitcoms it's
wild
it's wild i think people will be very
excited
so this is a little bit different than
what we've actually seen with the one
division teaser trailer the one division
teaser was
truly awesome but we didn't really see
any action but according to tayonna
paris there's going to be
a lot of action and that makes a lot of
sense because based off of what we know
and what we've heard
we are going to see wanda turn into the
true
scarlet witch and actually go by that
title and the scarlet witch is one of
the most powerful
marvel characters to ever be created in
the entire marvel comics universe and in
the mcu
and you don't give a character as
powerful as the scarlet witch her own tv
show if you're not going to show how
powerful she
truly is and since the show is supposed
to be action-packed that means we're
definitely going to be seeing
a lot of the scarlet witch's power and
of course that's going to lead
up to doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness where we'll probably see her
go full scarlet witch
and the great news is we don't have that
much longer to wait as it should be
coming in december which means we should
be getting another trailer for the one
division series either at the end of
this month or
very early of next month and when we
finally get the show it will be the
official start of marvel's phase four
so be sure to subscribe so you stay up
to date on all the latest mcu news and
be sure to let me know your thoughts
about one division being like an
action-packed movie let me know what you
think in the comments down below don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof